Speaker 1: And this is actually very interesting
news.
X White House counsel lawyer Don McGann will
have to testify behind closed doors about
Donald Trump's efforts to obstruct the Russia
investigation.
Now, again, I know that whenever this comes
up, some some portion of the audience will
say, David, you've fallen for this conspiracy
or that conspiracy or whatever the case may
be.
I'm not falling for anything.
I don't think this will lead to any repercussions
for Donald Trump.
Trump is out of office.
The ship has sailed.
The Russia probe was never going to result
in Trump being charged or removed or anything
like that.
But Don McGann is a guy who, as White House
counsel, was privy to all sorts of relevant
actions by Donald Trump and who has been ignoring
and avoiding congressional subpoenas for a
really long time.
It has now been determined that he indeed
is going to have to testify.
Donnegan will testify before the House Judiciary
Committee.
Yes.
Behind closed doors about Donald Trump's attempt
to obstruct the Russia probe.
The House and the Justice Department have
announced this in a court filing Wednesday
night.
Why a court filing, if it's a testimony that
will take place behind closed doors for a
political body because he had been ignoring
the subpoena, the interview was going to happen,
quote, as soon as possible.
There will be a transcript released so we
will know the substance.
CNN reports that the committee members who
interview him again can ask him about the
incidents documented in the Mueller report
of Donald Trump's attempts to fire Robert
Mueller to block the Russia investigation
and about the accuracy of that investigation.
The Justice Department can assert executive
privilege or Meghann can decline to answer
on other topics that will prevent House Democrats
from learning details about other Trump era
scandals.
Which is too bad, but this is still better
than nothing.
And this is a major concession from the executive
branch because for years the Trump administration
was trying to block exactly this from happening.
And this became something that went into court
because of the degree to which Don McGann
was just being obstinate on it.
And we are now going to get at least some
information.
So it's been a two year standoff.
It went to court.
It's now over Democrats.
Wanted Don McGann to testify, he's going to
testify, but it will be behind closed doors,
there will be a transcript and the topics
that are acceptable for which he will be forced
to answer have been outlined.
And they are the conclusions of the Mueller
investigation, Trump trying to obstruct the
investigation and fire Mueller and the accuracy
therein.
But beyond that, Don McGann can say, not going
to answer, not going to answer.
My expectation is Democrats will try on some
of those other topics, knowing that Don McGann
is going to decline to answer merely to get
that on the record, although in transcript
form, it's definitely less interesting or
dramatic than in video form.
And I look forward to reading very much about
this.
If you are skeptical that it will lead to
anything, I'm right there with you.
I am not reporting this to you as wow, look
at this bombshell.
We're about to hear all these unbelievable
things from Don.
No, no, no, no.
I understand that that's not going to be the
case.
Please don't come back to me in six months
and say.
But, David, you were saying that the Don Meghann
testimony was going to be some kind of blockbuster
of it.
No, I'm just curious to see what he says.
It's a great thing that he wasn't able to
fully avoid this.
It's been a two year court battle and it is
ultimately going to be going to court and
that's going to court decided he will have
to testify.
And I look forward to seeing what he says
and how evasive he is.
And we'll see what happens beyond that.
Monday, Memorial Day, we will be doing a single
day membership special just one day.
If you've been thinking maybe I'll get a membership
someday, if you've been thinking, maybe I'll
use one of those coupon codes Monday, Memorial
Day is the day to do it, OK?
It will be a one day membership special.
If you want to be notified, just get on my
newsletter.
You can do that at David Pakman Dotcom.
Sign up for the newsletter Monday, Memorial
Day.
You'll get an email and it will tell you exactly
how to take advantage of this coupon code,
as well as exactly what that coupon code is.
All right.
Let me know what stories you're watching a
find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
We have a it's just like a packed program
today.
We may oftentimes after these shows are done,
we just delete the files when we don't feel
very good about the show.
A lot of deletions have taken place.
We're keeping today's show archive because
it's bound to be a very good one.
We'll be right back after this.
All right, remember that the best way to support
The David Pakman Show continues to be it hasn't
changed becoming a member at Join Pakman dot
com, it's incredible how consistent that is.
You can sign up if you want a coupon code
using the code better 21 or pay full price,
which
is still very, very reasonable.